this week we were all urged to become
counterterrorism citizens and why I'd
urge you to go to the phone instantly
and share with all Thorat ease any
concerns you have about any suspicious
behavior am I the only one to question
the schemes worth a brief look at the
case of Ahmed Hassan the Parsons green
tube bomber whose murderous intent was
only fall due to his Blessed utter
incompetence is enough to cause concern
vial Hassan arrived in this country age
16 hiding in the back of a truck he'd
been orphaned by the war in Iraq shortly
after his arrival he told home office
officials he'd been recruited by the
Islamic state group and had been trained
to kill he was referred to the
anti-terror prevent program but after
just a week was judged quotes no cause
for concern mercifully no one was killed
by his makeshift bomb though 30 people
were injured now if we can't pick up
someone like Hassan what is the point of
an initiative like this if police get
tip offs they have to act on them Nick
this is such an important area and that
we are living in a world and in a
country where sadly things are getting
more and more dangerous
and what's the irony of it all since
Tereza May became Home Secretary in 2010
what has happened to our police force
while the world has got more and more
dangerous we've cut our police force the
funding has been cut by almost 20% the
number of police
INRI and absolutely and if we're should
be increasing to cope with the problems
we have what about the the bhabi on the
street visible policing which has always
been the number of police stations that
have been shut down including my local
police station yeah
neighbourhood policing which is so
important that's where they pick up
information that's where they hear
things from the people on the street
that's when they spot things has been
cut over 20,000 our police force of them
cut and on top of that armed policing
has gone down by over 1,000 when armed
policing should be increased sadly this
week we're remembering what happened at
Westminster I was trapped in there for
for those you know thousand hours and
sadly PC Keith Palmer died
and other citizens were killed that day
and armed policing is required more than
ever if there were if there were an
armed guards at that place if he was
armed the terrorists would have died not
be see Keith Palmer so I think we have
been negligent as a country negligent in
terms of cutting our police force and
that is the core problem over here yes
of course the public have gotta be
vigilant no question about it and what
the police say is about 20% of what is
reported by suspicious people being
suspicious is actually turns out
something genuinely dangerous though I'm
all for that but the core problem is
we've cut up police force that's
negligent yeah I am trying to agree with
you on
I don't think that we're gonna stop
terrorism by having bobbies on the
street I don't where I'm from you ask
McCall de grasa and if you're seen
talking to a Bobby on the be about the
bloke down the road is probably not
going to end very well so actually I am
a brave and they do it they get so much
you know how much most crimes most
homicide is solved through information
information but on the ground
if you see someone buying enormous
amounts of chemicals or higher they're
not going to I completely applaud these
mechanisms for people so I also disagree
with you because I think that we should
be vigilant citizens I think that we
should be helping the police in their
thing
and actually I think that what we need
is these prevent strategies the
mechanisms to report that I've seen this
person doing something a bit dodge
whether it's buying all this stuff or
doing this stuff we find someone like
actually what fills me with absolute
dread is the amount of people who were
deemed to be a risk a terrorism risk
that are wandering the street well
they're being watched I think wandering
the streets they are being monitored in
let's bring other people in now welcome
Jim
yeah well I'm really surprised Nick that
you're so passionately against this
measure I would have thought that this
would be the sort of thing that you'd be
in favor of only if they follow it up to
go back to you yeah so back to what
Karen was
in terms of the stats I've got a stat
that I'd like to bring up which is in
2017 there were 30,000 984 calls made to
the counter-terror unit 21.5 percent of
them actually helped with live
investigations so this stuff works and
also I've heard you many times on this
show being a favor of the Bobby on the
beat positive local policing how is this
just not a national version of that I've
clearly not represented myself and I
know you want to come back
of course people should proponent with
tips but as and when they are then they
go off these people must get proper
terms they must act you agree with it
you're just saying you want to see
follow information clearly didn't
Parsons Green make subjects given what
we talked about earlier with the news
Russians security threat from Russian I
think it's a super hopes all of us to be
citizen policemen or whatever in
anti-terror citizens the prevent program
doesn't work clearly no well wick read
the Parsons green bomber this is what
the security minister says I welcome the
conviction of Hasan who sought to spread
terror in this country and murder
innocent people it is clear that there
are some lessons to be learned in this
particular case police and local council
have conducted in an internal review
into how it was handled and we are
working with our partners to review the
findings and to interview where further
improvements can be made from the Home
Office I mean actually there was a story
this morning where if you do ring 999 to
report you can take from one out of 50
now look at initiatives that have been
around for many years like Crimestoppers
where you can phone it anonymously
yes and report a crime and that has been
seen to be very very effective years
with the prevent strategy it's a good
idea but working but the reality is so
many of the people are radicalized when
they go into prison they get radicalized
when they come back and it's very
difficult to dear addict lies somebody
who is an is fanatic for example and
that's been that's the challenge it is
so difficult to do this nice prevent but
we also need the ability for people to
be able to anonymously
whether through Crimestoppers whether
it's whichever way they do it but for
nine nine nine not to respond
to say not that prevents not working and
it's been useless but actually to
encourage communities to call out the
people they suspect in their communities
and we know what we're talking about
when it comes to Islamic terrorism but
if a bloke is on his way for an
interview to a home office official and
he says I've been trained to kill and
I'm a fan of is and we still don't take
action what is the point of all these
initiatives when we've shown that 21.5
percent have helped to form live
investigation that's one example hold on
and for the 30 people who are injured
and the others who were traumatized we
are so fortunate no one died at us I'm
not being forced anding what they went
through so that would have been awful it
and the way he packed it Michelle you
wanted to come I agree with you I still
don't see the investment to me needs to
be going into the counterterrorism into
things like prevent it doesn't need to
be going into Bobby's on the beat I
think it just bubbles on the beat it is
at least the police force is highly
under-resourced do you speak to any I
mean Teresa may was seen to be really
tough to be standing up to the police
now we look back and we say we've been
negligent we need our police force to be
invested in in terms of numbers in terms
of equipment in terms of armed officers
we want to feel safe as citizens we want
our police to have that ability to
protect us and and they they're being
cut and cotton cotton I think that is
completely negligent